en forme pour nous répondre voilà donc
pour cette audition d'arnaud montebourg
à suivre la suite des discussions sur le
collectif budgétaire 2012 il s'agit du
premier acte du quinquennat de françois
hollande qui est débattu toute la
semaine au sénat après avoir été adoptée
par l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle la séance est reprise nous
reprenons la discussion du projet de loi
de finances rectificatif pour 2012
la discussion générale les clauses nous
passons la discussion de la motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
monsieur philippe dallier les membres du
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
ont déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro un tendon a opposé la question
préalable au texte en discussion
ce fidèle à la parole merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'espagne s'enfonce dans
la crise
les marchés financiers s'affolent les
agences de notation s'interroge
maintenant sur la capacité de
l'allemagne à faire face et pendant ce
temps là que faisons nous c'est le sens
de la question préalable que j'ai
l'honneur de défendre au nom du groupe
ump sur le premier texte financier que
nous présente ce gouvernement objet une
question préalable sur collègues vous
savez aussi bien que moi avec
s'interroger sur l'opportunité d'un
texte c'est à dire et sur les ministres
si cette question nous semble pertinente
quand nous nous interrogeons sur
l'adéquation des dispositions de votre
collectif à la situation du pays de
l'europe et du monde
si j'osais pour décrire ce sentiment de
décalage que nous ressentons je parlerai
de l'insoutenable légèreté du moment
paraphrasant le président d'autres
commissions des finances alors
rapporteur général qui avait parlé de
l'insoutenable légèreté de la tête
en effet le premier texte financier
d'une nouvelle législature a fortiori
d'une nouvelle majorité revêtent un
caractère hautement symbolique
on était donc en droit d'espérer que ce
collectif nous démontre que vous avez
pris la mesure des choses et qu'ils
tracent clairement pour les cinq années
à venir
le chemin de la future politique
économique et budgétaire du gouvernement
ce n'est manifestement pas le cas de ce
texte sans grandes ambitions
qui a pourtant un mérite celui de nous
renseigner sur ce que sera le fil
d'ariane de votre politique augmentation
des impôts et des taxes en tous genres à
l'exclusion de toute économie auquel
vous vous refusez encore mais pour
combien de temps quant à comprendre ce
que vous comptez faire par exemple pour
améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises sujet majeur s'il en est ce
n'est pas ici que nous trouvons la
réponse au contraire vos premières
décisions vont la dégrader
comment trouverez vous les 25 à 30
milliards qu'il vous faudra dégager l'an
prochain pour rester en ligne avec notre
objectif de réduction du déficit public
pas plus de réponse ici il nous faudra
donc attendre la loi de finances
initiale pour 2013 afin d'y voir plus
clair
même si les ballons d'essais ont été
lancés je pense à la csg notamment mais
à ce jour le parlement reste dans la
tente de vos décisions
alors que le temps presse de plus en
plus c'est pourquoi nous nous
interrogeons très sérieusement messieurs
les ministres
avez-vous bien pris la mesure de la
gravité de la crise économique et de
l'urgence qu'elle impose
avez-vous bien conscience contrairement
à ce que dit madame aubry des marges de
manoeuvre réduite dont vous disposez
etes-vous véritablement décidé à engager
la france sur la voie du retour à
l'équilibré de nos comptes publics et
d'une meilleure compétitivité de nos
entreprises dans les meilleurs délais si
la réponse à ces questions est oui et je
veux bien vous en faire crédit messieurs
les ministres alors que faisons-nous là
si ce n'est perdre du temps
croyez vous que nous soyons à l'abri
derrière les décisions prises lors du
dernier sommet de bruxelles que vous
nous avez peut-être un peu trop vite
présenté comme un brillant succès de la
diplomatie française préférant lâcher
l'allemagne s'est allié si peu solide
pour nouer une alliance de revers avec
deux états en pleine prospérité l'italie
et l'espagne
à l'évidence le texte d'où notamment
aujourd'hui l'examen n'est pas le texte
fondateur d'une nouvelle majorité
pas plus qu'ils ne répondent pas à
l'urgence il n'est qu'un simple
collectif budgétaire à portée limitée
alors soit même si nous le déplorons
puisque vous le voulez ainsi et bien
examinons le cocktail ce collectif
permet tine selon l'esprit de la lolf
d'adapter au plus près de l'évolution de
la conjoncture
les prévisions de recettes et de
dépenses de l'année en 2011 nous en
avions examiné quatre le gouvernement
d'alors à être ainsi voulu jouer la plus
grande transparence face à une
conjoncture qui se dégradent est plus
vite que prévu et à l'époque notre
ancien collègue nicole bricq n'avait pas
manqué de critiquer cette méthode
reprochant au ministre du budget de
toujours surestimé le taux de croissance
alors même qu'en 2011 nous avions était
prudent aussi prudents que le consensus
des économistes
le changement venu nous serions donc mes
chers collègues en droit d'attendre du
nouveau gouvernement et collectif
budgétaire suffisamment prudent pour
être assuré de ne pas y revenir d'ici la
fin de l'année
je les ministres autant vous le dire
tout de suite je n'en crois rien pas
plus que notre rapporteur général
d'ailleurs respect en commission très
évasif sur le sujet alors mes chers
collègues je repose la question pourquoi
sommes-nous ici puisque nous nous
reverrons sous peu probablement en
septembre en octobre pour répondre à la
même question comment atteindre
l'objectif de 4 5% de déficit public en
le parlement réuni en session
extraordinaire en septembre et donc
mieux éclairer sur l'évolution de la
conjoncture n'aurait-il pas été plus
efficace
la réponse est certainement oui d'autant
qu'il existe une réserve de précaution
j'y reviendrai ce collectif budgétaire
n'est en réalité rien d'autre qu'une
entreprise de déconstruction un texte
purement idéologique dont l'unique
objectif est de défaire ce que la
majorité précédente a fait en quelque
sorte
l'ultime avatar de la campagne
électorale que vous avez en plus tentés
de dès 10 heures vous avez commencé par
nourrir le soupçon à l'égard de la
gestion de la précédente majorité vous
avez essayé d' instrumentaliser la cour
des comptes en lui demandant un audit
sur l'état de nos finances publiques
or chacun le sait la cour en chaque
année en juin un rapport sur la
situation et les perspectives des
finances publiques
il était donc inutile de parler d'audit
encore moins de faire peser le doute sur
l'indépendance de cette remarque à
l'institution
d'autant que le rapport rendu est sans
ambiguïté en constatant la mort ce une
stratégie de consolidation budgétaire
il donne acte ce rapport au précédent
gouvernement d'avoir remis les finances
publiques de notre pays sur une
trajectoire viable
une fois le premier choc de la crise
passée et ce choc fut très rude
vous oubliez mes chers collègues
systématiquement de le rappeler je le
ministre dans son propos cet après midi
nous a beaucoup parlé de 2007 nous a
beaucoup de parler de 2012 est de 2011
ils oublient simplement nous parlait
d'un événement majeur qu'a été la crise
de 2008 et 2009
et vous savez bien et vous savez bien
mes chers collègues l'impact qu'a eu
cette crise alors l'argument de l'audit
ayant fait pschitt
vous avez ensuite tenté pour justifier
l'urgence de faire croire que le
gouvernement précédent aurait laissé une
ardoise cachée d'une dizaine de
milliards mais cela non plus à tromper
personne
la cour des comptes l'a d'ailleurs
pleinement confirmé les moins-values de
recettes sont évaluées entre 5,8 et 10
milliards
vous retenez messieurs les ministres 7,1
pour l'ensemble d'année de l'année ces
moins-values s'expliquant pour
l'essentiel par les faibles rentrées de
l'impôt sur les sociétés dû au
ralentissement économique
mais pour faire flasher face à ces aléas
conjoncturels
la réserve de précaution disponible
était en mai dernier de 5 4 milliards le
chiffre vient de la cour des comptes
auxquels nous pouvons ajouter 800
millions en 2012 et 2,6 en année pleine
à partir de 2013 due à l'augmentation de
2 points des prélèvements sociaux sur
les revenus du capital que nous avons
votée et que vous maintenez alors qu'il
devait financer la baisse du coût du
travail dans le cadre de la tva
compétitivité voilà donc au total 6,2
milliards à votre disposition des
chenilles sur les 7,1 que vous cherchez
il n'y a donc aucune ardoise cacher ce
collectif budgétaire ne s'impose donc
pas dans l'immédiat en tout cas votre
premier souci est bien de défaire par
pure idéologie ce que la précédente
majorité a construit c'est bien là le
coeur de ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative
à ce titre je retiendrai trois mesure
emblématique la suppression brutale des
exonérations de charges et la
refiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires l'augmentation des
droits de succession la suppression de
la tva compétitivité et en plus vous
voudriez nous faire croire contre
l'évidence que toutes ces réformes sont
justes et ne toucheront pas les classes
moyennes
chacun sait bien ce qu'il en est la
suppression des exonérations d'heures
supplémentaires a bénéficié à 9 millions
de salariés qui gagne 1500 euros par
mois environ et perçoivent ainsi à peu
près 450 euros de plus par an est-ce que
ceux là sont les riches dont vous parlez
tout le temps est ce que ce sont eux qui
doivent payer pour réduire nos déficits
riches
l'aide-soignante hospitalière où
l'enseignant qui travaille quelques
heures de plus par mois riche
l'ouvrier ou la jambe catégorie c'est la
fonction publique où est donc ici la
justice sociale et fiscale dont vous
targuez temps votre nuque réponse
et comme au bon vieux temps de la mise
en place des 35 heures une conception
malthusienne du travail le travail
aurait atteint son maximum et
deviendrait rare il n'y aurait donc une
solution le partager mesdames et
messieurs quelle erreur
non messieurs les ministres n'est pas en
pénalisant les heures supplémentaires
que vous créerez plus d'emplois c'est
une chimère en les supprimant vous
rigidifier un peu plus notre marché du
travail qui n'en avait vraiment pas
besoin en cette période quand un
abaissement des plafonds du plafond des
droits de succession de cent soixante à
cent mille euros
ils ne pénalisent pas vraiment les plus
aisés pour qui cette différence de 60000
euros ne représente proportionnellement
qu'une faible part de l'ensemble du
patrimoine transmis en revanche il
concernera bien les classes moyennes
notamment celles qui ont pu acquérir un
bien immobilier en zone urbaine tendu on
pense souvent à la région ile de france
et même un département comme la seine
saint denis
car votre dispositif ne tient pas compte
du renchérissement du coût de
l'immobilier
autre mesure totalement dogmatique la
suppression de la tva compétitivité nos
entreprises de nos bêtises et qui était
un moyen d'accroître à court terme la
compétitivité nos entreprises par une
baisse des charges patronales
cette mesure était calibré pour être
faiblement
inflationnistes le moins possible et la
plus créatrice d'emplois possible
puisqu'elle était ciblée sur les bas
salaires
elle avait aussi l'extrême avantage de
porter sur les importations et de les
faire ainsi contribuer au financement de
notre protection sociale
là aussi par pure démagogie vous
supprimez le dispositif alors que la
commission européenne comme la cour des
comptes vous conseille de ne pas
augmenter les prélèvements pesant sur le
coût du travail et vous faites le
contraire
dans la tente à l'automne peut-être de
vous résoudre à augmenter la csg mais
dans quel but réduire le déficit réduire
le coût du travail
un peu des deux vous ne dites pas pas
plus que vous ne dit que cette
augmentation de la csg se traduira par
une baisse du pouvoir d'achat de façon
peut-être plus sensible encore pour les
mauvaises pour les plus modestes que
celles de la tva en effet messieurs les
ministres
notre dispositif ne touchait pas aux
taux applicable aux produits de première
nécessité qui représente une part plus
importante dans le panier de la ménagère
mollesse par ailleurs il est assez
facile de comprendre que ceux qui
consomment le plus les plus aisés aurait
été plus impactées surtout je le répète
les importations étaient mises à
contribution
c'est là tout l'intérêt de cette tva
vous préférez vous enfermer dans votre
dogmatisme nous le regrettons d'autant
plus que vos choix sont dangereux d'un
point de vue économique car ils
renchérissent le coût du travail
c'est bien le cas pour le retour partiel
à la retraite à 60 ans financée par une
hausse de cotisations
du coup de pouce au smic de la tva de
l'abandon de la tva compétitivité de la
suppression des exonérations sur les
heures supplémentaires
comment peut-on nier à ce point la
réalité et les expériences de nos
partenaires européens qui ont réussi par
l'abaissement ou la limitation du coût
du travail à obtenir des résultats
meilleurs que les nôtres en termes de
croissance et d'emploi je la vis une
première loi de finances pour une
nouvelle majorité aurait dû à tout le
moins
donner les orientations stratégiques
fixés le cas or nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans la confusion la plus totale
il nous est très difficile de discerner
vos choix y compris pour la loi de
finances initiale que nous discuterons à
la rentrée vous renoncez déjà à les
promesses du candidat hollande
et parfois ce n'est pas plus mal par
exemple la réforme de la fiscalité des
carburants qui aurait vraisemblablement
été coûteuse et faiblement efficace
vous êtes en train de prendre conscience
de l'inutilité du doublement du plafond
du livret à qui déstabiliserait
profondément le marché de l'épargné et
reviendrait à créer une nouvelle niche
fiscale pour les plus aisés ce qui
serait quand même un comble vous
annoncez des dépenses supplémentaires
plus de contrats aidés augmentation de
l'allocation rentrée scolaire hausse du
smic sans dire comment elles seront
financées ce qui rendra l'ajustement
structurel de nos finances publiques
encore plus difficile quand vous aurez à
le faire parce qu'il faudra bien le
faire vous n'envisagez pas de réduire
sérieusement la dépense publique
au contraire vous annoncer la création
de postes dans certains secteurs de la
fonction publique et vous ne dites pas
quelles en seront les conséquences pour
les autres or un rapide calcul montre
que hors secteurs prioritaires
on ne peut maintenir les effectifs que
par le nom revue le non
renouvellement de deux départs sur trois
et vous juger si sévèrement notre règle
du un sur deux à ce stade
votre réforme de l'impôt sur les
sociétés n'est pas clair du tout et on
ne sait pas comment elle s'articule avec
votre projet de refonte de la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
à moins que vous ne l'ayez également
déjà abandonné quant à la fusion de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de la csg
on en entend plus parler où allez vous
comment réussir et vous dans ces
conditions le rééquilibrage de nos
finances publiques
malheureusement vos projets pour ce que
nous en savons aujourd'hui augmenteront
le coût du travail et la dépense
publique
il ne vous reste alors qu'un moyen de
les financer l'augmentation des impôts
et des taxes
c'est la logique dans laquelle vous êtes
la conséquence est un choc fiscal dont
notre pays aura du mal à sortir un même
ce choc a été évalué à 30 milliards par
le président notre commission des
finances ce n'est pas une bagatelle
alors faudrait-il au moins avoir le
courage de le dire clairement à nos
concitoyens et à la représentation
nationale
pour conclure nous souhaitons que le
principe de réalité l'emportent et que
vous tiriez les leçons de 1981 ou plutôt
de 1983 car en économie le dogmatisme et
dangereux surtout que la dévaluation
n'est plus possible et que l'an prochain
notre pays sera vraisemblablement le
premier émetteur de dette de la zone
euro
ce principe de réalité signifie monsieur
le ministre que le gouvernement aurait
dû engager sans tarder les réformes qui
assureront la compétitivité notre pays
seul moyen de créer des emplois et de
préserver notre modèle social
or le présent projet de loi de finances
rectificative ne répond pas à cet
objectif
ce n'est pas une loi de réforme fiscale
ce n'est qu'un règlement de comptes post
électorale qui ne prépare pas l'avenir
et pour quand il y a urgence messieurs
les ministres non ce texte n'est pas
celui dont la france a besoin
il aimait mortifère car ils seraient nos
oreilles de nos compatriotes une petite
musique celle d'une chanson titre et
figures qui préfigura une grande
catastrophe
tout va très bien madame la marquise
tout va très bien tout va très bien
seulement il faut que l'on vous dise on
déplore un tout petit rien c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues au long du
groupe l'ump j'ai l'honneur de vous
demander de voter cette question
préalable
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean germain
contre la motion
si le président messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
monsieur d'allier et son groupe estime
que le présent projet de loi de finances
rectificative ne répond pas aux
circonstances
il ajoute que les propos du ministre
dans la préface dans la présentation de
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative ne l'ont pas suffisamment
renseignés nous n'avons certainement pas
assisté à la même séance puisque je
crois partager le sentiment de beaucoup
de collègues et dans cet hémicycle nous
avons eu je pense un exposé extrêmement
clair des réponses précises et j'ajoute
une prestation brillante je dirais à
monsieur d'allier à son groupe que dans
sa présentation
il n'est fait nulle part mention d'un
élément extrêmement important qui a été
au pouvoir dans les dix dernières années
et qui est qui et qui
et qui laisse le pays dans cet état je
ne vais pas je ne vais pas faire un
un panorama complet indiquant où visant
à indiquer finalement qu'est ce que
serait une bonne politique économique et
fiscale
je pense que les ministres qui sont ici
je le dis parce que je le crois sont
plus capables que moi de le faire mais
je voudrais répondre à la question qui
sous-tend finalement votre question
préalable le prix jean le présent projet
de loi de finances ne propose pas une
réforme fiscale mais une revanche fiscal
alors sans effet de manche mais en
essayant d'être très sérieux je voudrais
essayer de vous dire comment je ressens
ce dont on parle
quelle est cette revanche fiscal dont
serez coupable le gouvernement il me
semble que pour procéder à un
redressement des finances publiques dont
notre pays a besoin
mais dans un souci de justice le
gouvernement a tout simplement décidé de
faire surtout appel à la contribution de
ceux qui ont bénéficié parfois de
manière déraisonnable des décisions de
ces dernières années et je voudrais
reprendre ses impôts qui sont présentés
dans le projet de loi finances
rectificative les uns après les autres
la contribution exceptionnelle sur la
fortune faire contribuer davantage les
contribuables les plus fortunés à
l'effort financier national tout en
répartissant équitablement la charge
fiscale supplémentaire que suppose ce
redressement
c'est une revanche contre qui contre les
plus fortunés contre ceux qui ont été
ultra protégée par la kyrielle de
mesures d'exonération prises par le
gouvernement précédent contre ceux qui
ont été littéralement assisté par l'état
c'est à dire par les plus nombreux par
les plus modestes revanche non
contribution à l'effort national de
diminution de la dette creusée en grande
partie par les allègements fiscaux
accordée à ceux qui souffraient le moins
du poids de la fiscalité la suppression
des allègements sociaux et fiscaux
attachés aux heures supplémentaires
dans la situation présente de la france
alors que le chômage est massif que les
destructions d'emplois se multiplient et
que les capacités de production sont
excédentaires au regard de la demande
la france était sans doute le seul pays
au monde à avoir institué un système de
destruction d'emplois financés par des
fonds publics cette suppression
c'est une revanche contre qui est vite
et éviter une hausse de 1,6 point du
taux normal de tva éviter une hausse de
1,6 point du tout normal de tva qui
auraient été préjudiciables au pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et partant à la
consommation et la croissance c'est une
revanche contre qui le maintient de la
hausse des prélèvements sociaux sur les
revenus du capital
les revenus du capital ne devrait il pas
participer au progrès de la justice
fiscale
je rappelle qu'une part de cette
ressource sera affectée à la caisse
nationale des allocations familiales
afin de financer le relèvement de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
revanche contre qui une autre part sera
affectée à la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse dont la situation
se trouve plus dégradée que ce qui avait
été présenté au parlement dans le cadre
de la réforme des retraites de 2010
revanche contre qui le doublement de la
taxe de risque systémique des banques
une taxe de risque systémique est
acquittée par certaines entreprises du
secteur bancaire relevant de la
compétence de l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et soumises à des exigences
minimales en fonds propres le doublement
de cette taxe est il une revanche ou le
simple renforcement de précaution d'une
assurance
contre un risque que nous n'arrivons pas
à écarter faute de pouvoir imposer des
règles prudentielles suffisamment
contraignante un secteur économique
puissant et trop fréquemment imprudent
le versement anticipé de la contribution
exceptionnelle de l'impôt sur les
sociétés revanche je crois que le
ministre cet après midi l'a bien
expliqué ce n'est qu'une anticipation et
qui est nécessaire dans le cadre des
recettes de l'état en 2012
la contribution exceptionnelle du
secteur pétrolier
c'est une contribution exceptionnelle
due au titre de l'année 2012 par les
entreprises détentrices de volumes de
produits pétroliers placé sous un régime
suspensif fiscal situé sur le territoire
de la france métropolitaine
c'est une revanche n'est-il pas normal
de faire contribuer à l'effort national
un secteur florissant dont les profits
sont réalisés essentiellement à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
la hausse du forfait social
ce forfait a été institué pour faire
contribuer certains accessoires du
salaire au financement du système
solidaire de sécurité sociale il
s'agissait d'atténuer les différences en
termes de taux de prélèvements sociaux
entre les gains et rémunérations
assujetties aux cotisations sociales est
certaine forme particulière de
rémunération ce forfait relève en
matière de contributions patronales
d'une logique très proche de celle qui
s'applique pour les salariés avec la
contribution sociale généralisée et je
rappelle que le produit de cette hausse
sera réparti entre la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et le fonds de
solidarité vieillesse
la situation de ce régime et de ce fonds
s'avérant nettement plus dégradée que ce
qui avait été présenté au parlement dans
le cadre de la réforme des retraites de
2010 revanche contre qui
le doublement de la taxe sur les
transactions financières le secteur
financier a bénéficié à la suite de la
crise de 2008 d'un important soutien des
états en conséquence le gouvernement a
considéré qu'il était légitime de faire
contribuer le secteur financier à
l'effort collectif de redressement des
finances publiques
d'autant que les cris que la crise est
en partie le fruit du dysfonctionnement
des marchés financiers revanche non
normale et honnête retour sur
investissement pour reprendre un
vocabulaire économique la hausse des
droits de mutation de nombreux
allègement de droits de mutation à titre
gratuit consentis depuis 2007 notamment
par la loi tepa de 2007 ont
principalement bénéficié aux
contribuables les plus aisés dans la
mesure où seule la moitié des ménages
vivant en france déclarent posséder plus
de cent cinquante mille deux cents euros
de patrimoine brut soit un niveau
supérieur à celui auquel a été portée
l'abattement en ligne directe par la
dite loi tepa revanche contre qui contre
les héritiers
on pourrait à la rigueur parlait de
fiscalité pesant sur ce qui laisse un
héritage important mais de revanche
contre les héritiers point du tout mais
je rappelle que notre constitution
proclame que la france est une
république sociale qui recherchent
l'égalité réelle et partant la
diminution des inégalités surtout
passive et l'héritage en est une
importante
la hausse la hausse du prélèvement
social sur les stock options le niveau
des prélèvements sociaux sur les stock
options pose un problème d'égalité entre
les salariés n'ayant pas accès à ces
formes particulières de rémunération et
ceux qui en bénéficient et qui sont
souvent les mieux rémunérés dans
l'entreprise la mesure prise dans le
pool projet de loi de finances
rectificative vise donc à renforcer la
convergence entre différentes formes de
rémunération dont certaines souffrent
d'une faible utilité économique et
social et ne sont pas liées à une
production de valeur alors qu'elles vont
pouvoir apporter des ressources
nouvelles
utile au financement de la protection
sociale collective revanche
poser la question c'est y répondre et
par la négative
mes chers collègues je pense que s'il ya
une revanche
la présentation de ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative et surtout larves
ans de la réflexion sur l'improvisation
permanente et l'adaptation aux sondages
d'opinion
c'est la revanche de la réflexion sur la
situation économique et sociale de notre
pays c'est la revanche de la réflexion
sur la nécessité de faire que chacun
puisse participer à l'effort de
redressement national
selon ses facultés contributives et dans
cette enceinte finalement est-ce quelque
chose de très différent de ce à quoi
elle nous avons appelé au travers des
siècles nos compatriotes et notamment
ici clemenceau lorsque il appelait pour
l'effort de guerre en 1917 chacun à
participer à cet effort à due
concurrence de son revenu de sa
situation
nous sommes dans une période nous sommes
dans une période de guerre économique
et finalement ce à quoi nous amène et
nous demande de faire le gouvernement
c'est de participer à cet effort de
redressement de notre pays de le faire
finalement dans la plus grande justice
est en tous les cas au moment où nous
parlons
cela reçoit l'accord d'une importante
majorité de nos concitoyens
merci chers colle d'ailleurs je vais
demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président la question
préalable qui est déposée relève donc de
du 3 de l'article 44 du règlement du
sénat
comme vous le savez et cette question
peut être adopté pour que le sénat
décide un qu'il s'oppose à l'ensemble du
texte ou 2 qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
poursuivre la délibération alors j'ai
cru constater si jean juste parce que
j'ai entendu tout cet après midi lors de
la discussion qu'il y avait à première
vue une majorité pour ne pas s'opposer à
l'ensemble du texte
il y a au contraire lieu de poursuivre
la délibération me semble-t-il ne
serait-ce que mes chers collègues pour
débattre de ces nombreux amendements que
l'opposition a bien voulu déposés sur ce
texte que vous souhaitez bien sûr voir
des battu ici même donc je crois que la
commission des finances qui a été saisi
il ya un instant de cette proposition de
questions préalables a jugé que
il n'y avait pas à vous suivre sur
l'adoption de questions préalables et
qu'il était opportun de poursuivre la
discussion au sénat sur ce plfr qui a on
l'a rappelé des enjeux assez
considérable tant sur la place de la
france en europe à travers l'image qui
est restituée par ses comptes et les
évolutions budgétaires souhaitées et
bien entendu quant à la mise en oeuvre
des orientations qui ont été validées
par les électeurs il ya quelques
semaines il semble très important que ce
le plfr puisse véritable outil dans les
délais qui ont été retenus et dans ces
conditions je m'oppose bien entendu la
commission va suivi sur ce plan à
l'adoption de cette question préalable
merci on aventure monsieur le ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'avis du gouvernement ne sera pas
positif vous vous en doutez je voudrais
tout d'abord vous priez d'excusés mon
absence de cet après midi qui m'a
empêché d'assister à cette séance mais
il se trouve qu'il y avait des questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée nationale
certaines un peu agressive une situation
de la zone euro qui justifiait que nous
soyons est bien là ici au sénat et
l'autre à l'assemblée et puis vous avez
pu avoir ce débat avec jérôme cahuzac
avec alain vidalis le glandon ne chôme
pas
contrairement à ce que peuvent prétendre
certains sénateurs de l'opposition et
pour ma part chez vous le savez le plus
grand respect pour cette haute assemblée
ce qui explique que je vienne pour
répondre ici et maintenant
alors pour ce qui concerne la question
préalable les auteurs de cette motion
estime que le projet de loi de finances
rectificative ne propose pas une réforme
fiscale mais une revanche fiscale et
c'est sans surprise mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je me tourne vers la majorité que jour
demanderai le
roger jean leman dray le rejet parce que
je crois que outre le jeu de mots qui
est de qualité discutable qui préfère
souligner je préfère souligner les
enjeux il rappelé que nous nous
cherchons à accomplir plutôt que de
gloser sur je ne sais quel contenu
idéologique supposé de notre action dans
tout ce que nous entreprenons dans tout
ce que nous entreprenons monsieur le
président est fier de vous comporter
avec la dignité qui convient à votre
fonction plutôt qu'en porte-parole
idéologique d'un parti calmez vous c'est
très mauvais vous savez
je respecte l'opposition eh bien vous
exagérez quand même cas il ne m'a pas
semblé il ne m'a il ne m'a pas semblé
que l'interruption
il ne m'a pas semblé que l'interruption
et je dirais même l'interjection venait
de moi bien parfait je continue si vous
le voulez bien
monsieur le président allons alors alors
je n'ai surtout pas de leçon à recevoir
de vous donc je continue
si vous le voulez bien alors dans tout
ce que nous en prendrons je respecte
davantage l'opposition que vous le
respectez le gouvernement et la majorité
et donc je vous prierais aussi d'être
dans cette attitude là c'est je crois la
bonne j'en viens maintenant à ce qui
justifie nos choix c'est-à-dire de
déployer une politique cohérente juste
et un mot que nous aimons bien et que je
revendique hautement le mot de
réformistes et le projet de loi de
finances rectificative s'inscrit
clairement dans cette démarche
c'est une première étape et un double
titre première étape d'un redressement
budgétaire indispensable qui va se
dérouler sur l'ensemble du mandat qui va
évoluer progressivement les premières
étapes aussi d'une réforme profonde du
système fiscal que nous voulons
entreprendre que nous commençons
d'entreprendre
si donc pas une revanche c'est un jalon
c'est le premier jalon du redressement
dans la justice appelé par les français
de leurs voeux dès que le gouvernement
de jean marc ayrault est entré en
fonction il s'est appelé à traiter une
crise budgétaire aux origines anciennes
et dont nous connaissons en vérité les
responsabilités j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de répondre sur ce point aux sénateurs
d'ail et qui décidément insistent nos
objectifs en matière de finances
publiques
nause nos objectifs en matière on va
monsieur monsieur monsieur marriner vous
êtes assez incroyable tout de même
d'abord conserver votre sang froid
monsieur marc unique calmez vous je
réponds comme un discours de monsieur da
ye dont chacun a pu apprécier ici la
finesse l'objectivité la tolérance et
qui était en vérité un discours de
sectarisme
alors s'il vous plaît laissez aussi
répondre ça s'appelle la démocratie et
ça suppose à l'occasion une forme de
confrontation
je reviens au fond nos objectifs en
matière de finances publiques sont
ambitieux il s'agit de ramener le
déficit à 3% en 2013 de réduire le poids
de la dette dans la richesse nationale
dès 2014 puis de revenir à l'équilibré
chrome public en 2017
mais ce que je veux dire et je me tourne
vers la majorité c'est que nous ne
devons pas simplement assumer
nous devons défendre avec fierté la
trajectoire de finances publiques dans
lesquelles nous engageons qui est aussi
le marqueur d'un gouvernement qui sait
où il va et d'un président qui marque un
cap et cet effort de réduction des
comptes publics de redressement des
complices il va se partager
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendue
équitablement sur le mandat entre les
dépenses et les recettes
je la firme ici vous savez tous ce
qu'est ce que quelle est la rigidité de
la dépense publique en cours d'année
c'est pourquoi nous avons fait porter
essentiellement pour ce plfr l'effort
sur les recettes
mais en même temps non il n'y aura pas
de matraquage fiscal il n'y aura pas non
plus d'oublier des économies de dépenses
il y aura les deux à la fois de façon
équilibrée sur l'ensemble de la
mandature et jérôme cahuzac pour qui
vous votiez il ya une seconde
madame la sénatrice à rappeler ici que
sur l'année 2012 sur un point
d'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires
c'est vous qui est responsable de 0,8
point
ces 15 milliards d'euros soit deux fois
plus que ce que nous proposons ici et
même un peu plus de deux fois plus et
donc c'est à croire que certains aiment
la peau encore deux fois plus que nous
notre politique budgétaire a un objectif
que je redis c'est le redressement
budgétaire
permettez-moi de revenir brièvement pour
achever ma réponse sur le contenu de ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
que nous vous proposons aujourd'hui
idéologie dites-vous inopportun inutile
françois marque a montré au contraire
en quoi il était nécessaire en quoi il
fallait poursuivre le gouvernement
entend en priorité faire contribuer à
l'effort d'assainissement de nos comptes
ce que la crise a le plus épargné
c'est à dire les ménages qui disposent
d'une capacité d' épargne conséquente
qui supporteront près des trois quarts
du montant des prélèvements
supplémentaires sur les ménages et les
grandes entreprises qui sont chacun le
sait ici soumises à des taux
d'imposition effectif plus faible que
les pme pmi et là il ne s'agit pas
encore une fois d'une revanche mais de
justice lorsque certains secteurs
aujourd'hui très prospère conforté dans
une situation fiscale privilégiée par la
présente majorité contribueront
exceptionnellement d'ailleurs à l'effort
de redressement des comptes en 2012 et
je pense ici à la taxe sur la valeur des
stocks des produits pétroliers par
exemple qui est une charge à la fois
proportionnée et encore une fois juste
elle se justifie d'ailleurs par les
spécifités un secteur qui a vu ses
profits s'accroît considérablement
depuis 2004 et qui souvent échappent à
toute imposition en france la même
logique d'équité s'appliquer aux ménages
une contribution exceptionnelle
permettra en 2012 de compenser le coût
du bouclier fiscal qu'il va toucher les
personnes dont le patrimoine net
imposable est supérieur à 1,3 million
d'euros et une suppression temporaire du
plafonnement pour une seule année qui
n'a pas pour vocation de punir ni de
décourager l'épargné mais simplement
d'associer à l'effort de redressement
des comptes
ceux qui sont le plus en mesure de le
faire enfin je dirais quelques mots 2d
mais des entreprises où la même logique
vaut et aussi des exonérations de
cotisations sociales sur les heures
supplémentaires instaurée dans la part
la majorité présents dont je vous dirai
un mot un peu plus long j'entends ici
comme à l'assemblée nationale les
protestations de l'opposition que je
respecte
hautement mais les faits sont
malheureusement tu es tu les fais
nous disent que la loi tepa à laquelle
vous êtes toujours attaché à fait
malheureusement la preuve de son
inefficacité
comme l'a démontré le rapport de deux
députés un de l'opposition d'alors et de
la majorité d'alors monsieur malo et
monsieur gorge qui écrivait le mécanisme
n'a pas produit une augmentation
mesurable significative du nombre total
d'heures travaillées
si les heures supplémentaires ont
augmenté c'est largement parce qu'elles
ont été mieux déclaré voilà pour le
travailler plus et pire on estime c'est
ce qui a été fait aussi par ce rapport
les emplois détruits par la mesure où
non créés du fait de la mesure entre 40
et 80 milles sur la période convenait
que dans une france qui est aujourd'hui
minée par le chômage de masse c'est un
contre et fait et voilà pourquoi nous
assumons tranquillement cette mesure ce
n'est pas de l'idéologie c'est une
question de valeurs ce qu'une question
d'analysé économique c'est une
différence démocratique entre nous voilà
ce que je voulais dire simplement pour
répondre à votre motion vous avez évoqué
monsieur le sénateur d'allier une
revanche fiscale je ne vois pas là de
revanche aucune revanche je vois là la
justice ou un réquilibrage si nous
considérons que votre majorité d'alors a
sans cesse privilégier ceux qui étaient
les plus aisés je veux ajouter un
dernier mot pour terminer par là où vous
allez commencer par vos remarques sur la
zone euro que j'ai trouvé je lave ou du
plus mauvais goût
parce que cette question je veux le dire
ici n'est pas une question qui doit
justifier des divisions ou des
polémiques
vous avez parfaitement loin d'en parler
mais monsieur marini mais vous êtes
fatigant j'ai le droit aussi de répondre
je pense pour ma part je pense pour ma
part que cette question de la zone euro
ne souffre pas de divisions de
polémiques d'attac mesquine
d'utilisation nous avons toujours
lorsque nous étions dans l'opposition
était sur ce sujet parfaitement
patriotique car il faut prendre
conscience que c'est le pays tout entier
qui doit être mobile
viser pour dire à quel point nous sommes
attachés à l'euro et oui je le redis ici
devant votre assemblée
je considère en effet que le conseil
européen des 28 et 29 juin dont vous
vous êtes môquet est une étape
importante dans la stabilisation
financière de la zone euro
ce qu'il nous faut faire ce n'est pas
critiquer cela au prétexte que désormais
il y un autre président en france c'est
au contraire appliquées de manière
stricte et rapide de manière stricte et
rapide les décisions qui ont été prises
un paquet de croissance qui était
nécessaire des mesures de stabilité
financière indispensable une intégration
solidaire qui est l'avenir de l'europe
voilà moi ce que je constate c'est que
sur un sujet comme cela vous pousser des
hauts cris alors qu'en réalité on a
besoin de responsabilité et de
mobilisation et bien si vous ne voulez
pas être responsable sur cette question
nous le serons pour deux pour tous ces
motifs
je demande le rejet de cette motion
voilà donc pour les discussions autour
du collectif budgétaire de 2012 qui je
vous le rappelle est examiné toute cette
semaine au sénat
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours retrouver
la séance sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur la chaîne
parlementaire